hey everybody great to see you guys it's
been a few days since my laughs last
stream we are on the precipice once
again of Donald Trump's press secretary
Kelly McKenna knee and another press
briefing I cannot imagine what is going
to happen at today's press briefing
given the reality that the Trump White
House has collapsed there is a new poll
let's go over to my Twitter page a new
CNN poll this is a b-plus rated pollster
that has Joe Biden ahead fourteen points
against Donald Trump very important that
Biden is over fifty regularly right now
you might remember back in 2016 Hillary
Clinton would regularly be in 47 48 49
and her lack of regularly being above 50
was not a great sign needless to say we
know that now in retrospect now seeing
Joe Biden significantly over 50 this is
very bad for Donald Trump anything can
change Trump could end up getting
himself reelected of course but the
important thing that I want to point out
is that Trump and his campaign staff
know that this is not going well and the
coronavirus response has been a disaster
his totalitarian repressive response to
the protests has been a disaster
bunker boy record 200 tweets and
retweets in a day on Friday and so they
know they have to do something and one
of the things that is being considered
is a quote major speech on race which is
hilarious by the way the idea of Donald
Trump and a major speech speech on race
is funny just in principle but the point
is they're realizing that something
positive needs to come out of Trump and
everything is so negative everything is
vindictive everything is you know in the
last 48 hours
Mitt Romney Willard mittens marching
with protesters and saying black lives
matter the only sitting Republican
senator willing to do that
Trump attacks him Don jr. says who
thinks we give a [ __ ] whether he
supports
or not : powell lifelong republicans
saying i can't vote for trump he's a
persistent habitual liar I've got to
vote for Joe Biden and by the way I have
a a warning to those on the left that
we're going to publish later today we've
already recorded it where the people on
the Left who are saying the reason :
powell is voting Biden is cuz Biden's
really a Republican never Biden blah
right wrong analysis my friends the
right analysis is life long Republicans
are so disgusted with Trump that they
are choosing country over party that's
the news people who would never vote who
would never vote for a Democrat in any
normal circumstance are voting for a
Democrat in Biden who is to the left of
Hillary Clinton at least although listen
Biden is no progressive that's the news
they are saying I'm abandoning my party
because this is so bad I'm deciding not
on party lines but based on what is best
for the country so you know I the people
on the Left who are going to say Biden's
a Republican of course : Powell's voting
for him okay you know okay have fun with
that when my friends have have fun with
that one
okay we are standing by for Kayleigh Mac
and Annie at the top of the hour we
expect a short press briefing followed
by a few questions some of the questions
may be nasty I want to welcome everybody
watching on twitch thank you so much we
are going to be doing a lot more twitch
stuff upcoming and I appreciate
everybody watching there and I do want
to thank Todd Woodward as well as ap
prime for subscribing on Twitch love
those twitch subscriptions over on
YouTube super chats are starting to come
in and they will show up on the lower
left of the screen as they come in a
couple of them are just not visible
right now
Zachary Pro Kowski says first along with
a super chat thank you and Ken Clive
says do you think there will be a new
Labor Party emerged
after the 2020 election like the new
Democrats in Canada let's see how the
2020 election goes first and then we
will then then we will go from there
let's because we haven't done this for a
long time I know a lot of people owe
thanks to that darn Steve for the twitch
Prime subscription and jock wolf a lot
of people are no longer talking about
the corona virus pandemic I just
recorded an interview with Neil Ferguson
where he reminds us by the way that
nothing has changed this thing is still
going on and I do briefly want to look
at the numbers we now have over seven
million global confirmed coronavirus
cases and over 400,000 deaths we do have
as you can see here the pandemic is
building at a global level it is still
continuing to build at a global level in
terms of cases that is partially because
of testing it's also partially not yet
represented in deaths because a lot of
these cases are in just a few countries
if we sort by new cases you will see
that Brazil has become a big contender
for lots of new cases and they have a
system that is rapidly getting
overwhelmed oh we have a level 2 hype
train going on twitch very very exciting
India is increasingly a problematic
place Russia is having a real problem so
so we we are still having a real major
coronavirus pandemic we have no
treatment we have no vaccine remember we
have found over 2 million official cases
in the United States and are now
approaching a hundred and thirteen
thousand deaths increasingly the case is
coming in California and then a lot of
new red state entrance into most cases
Arizona and Virginia Florida New York
has been having problems for a long time
and they continue to but of course look
at their testing rate much higher than
all of these other top states Texas
really continuing let's just pick Texas
they were one of the places that
reopened early and they now have seen
what what is certainly not being past
the peak in fact they had their largest
number of new cases in a day
just three days ago death seemed to lag
that but again this is not bending the
curve or anything like it and lastly on
testing just a reminder let me move this
we finally have gotten to a couple of
days with five hundred thousand tests
it's June it is now June ok we should
have been at five hundred thousand a day
months ago we need to get to one or two
million a day to be safe we are still
not there and that that is sadly where
we are today so that is going on we do
have a continued hype train happening on
Twitch we are close to completing level
three here on watching on YouTube don't
worry about this this has nothing to do
with you but this is happening on Twitch
I want to say thanks to Leo gag and
Mister go7 as well as Peter Tai Schneids
and I'm inconsolable for the support
over on Twitch we are four minutes from
hopefully reaching a level four hype
train which is wild when that happens my
hair actually once combusted my hair was
set on fire by a level by a level four
hype train by the way speaking of hair I
do have a scheduled haircut now it's
conceivable that I would cancel it
honestly I spoke with Neil Ferguson
about this I don't know what's safe I I
really don't know what's safe right now
I mean you know there's few enough the
curve has improved so dramatically here
in Massachusetts that if I wear a mask
to get a haircut
and you know the hairdresser wears a
hair wears a mask it there's nobody
waiting in the waiting room it seems the
risk is relatively low so I mean this is
just it's insane what is going on and I
just have to I mean look at this that's
like eight inches you know something
like that I don't know how long that is
it's crazy what's going on so I do have
a haircut scheduled for this this Friday
and we'll see I mean we'll see if it if
it all happens oh my goodness that I
mean is this even legal in some of the
southern states
I think I wouldn't even be allowed in
with hair like this but so I'm
tentatively going to be getting a
haircut and we'll see how that goes but
what what is safe I don't know I mean
restaurants are able to open for outdoor
dining today in Massachusetts does that
mean it's okay to do small gatherings
with people who have mostly been staying
home I mean if it's okay to be at a
restaurant for an hour outside it's with
people you don't know
right the waitstaff and whatever wearing
masks is it okay now to see three
friends I don't know I don't know I
don't have the answers and this is part
of what I talked about with Neil
Ferguson
in the interview that we will be
publishing tomorrow we'll be publishing
that tomorrow a few other super chats
are coming in let's see here
Jacob Ratner asks am I worried about a
kovetz spike due to protests yeah of
course Mathew tree nard says if you were
Canadian who would you vote for by the
way bunker boy is officially Trump's new
nickname I I listen I like Justin
Trudeau I don't know what the other
options are so I would it wouldn't be
informed commentary maybe there's
someone better than Trudeau I don't know
Brody Andrew Mulligan says getting worse
here in Texas ICU beds running low
that's what I read Waller is me says
California reopening although our case
numbers are on the rise I see people out
and about acting as if the virus is gone
or doesn't matter and some local
vigilante groups are springing up scary
people leading them yeah I actually saw
California has been quote closed for a
really long time a lot of people seem to
just be ignoring it and the curve is not
good I mean listen for a state that's
been closed for three months
supposedly closed this is not the curve
that you want to see and according to my
brother who lives in California he said
that a lot of people are just ignoring
the rules and that that's that's what's
going on we have reached a level four
hype train on Twitch we have four and a
half minutes to complete it let's do it
thank you to braided solid 126
Doody Doody who says stay safe everybody
with their a twitch Prime subscription
very much appreciate that Captain Crunch
says David your video Trump sees 2020
map panics is extremely underrated I
couldn't agree more if Biden wants to
win in November
he needs to flip Ohio Pennsylvania
Michigan if he loses Florida thank you
Michael Scott Matthew says David the
hair looks amazing Jesse Lee Peterson
thank you very much I appreciate that
what else did I have oh I had a couple
other things on my Twitter account you
should by the way if you're not
following me on Twitter what are you
doing by the way here's a little
inception this is me watching my Twitter
feed of me talking about my Twitter feed
on Twitter while streaming in advance of
subsequent streams which which you can
imagine is very very exciting we have
our Trump Biden poll from earlier what
other things Oh check this out this is
Trump's advisor Larry Kudlow sounds like
a used car salesman check this out this
is wild America is coming back three
million new jobs lower unemployment rate
furloughed temporary layoffs going back
to work
green shoots popping up everywhere
stocks are soaring stumps Otis policies
are working stay with the winners Trump
and pence and me the best is have you
ever seen a bigger winner than Larry
Kudlow my goodness come on down by the
way they'll also give you free
rustproofing if you get the extended
warranty which is a really really really
good deal so there's that
here's willard mittens marching racism
we need many voices against racism and
against brutality okay so this is quite
quite a different timeline Oh Mazel Tov
cocktails that's really funny
anyway so people acted as if this was
like a title this is closed captioning
so Molotov cocktails was misinterpreted
as Mazel Tov and then check out if you
want to see tone-deaf check out Ivanka
Trump check this out Allan gist
sacrifices determination grit sweat and
likely even a few tears our entire
society has engaged in national endeavor
to guarantee the safety and well-being
of our people you have to
dominate the streets you are a wartime
graduate in my own life I found that my
greatest personal growth has arisen from
times of discomfort and uncertainty
the Chinese government awarded Ivanka
seven new trademarks hours later she
dined with the Chinese President and her
father's mar-a-lago resort Janka Trump
and Jared Kushner earned at least 82
million dollars last year throughout our
history brave men and women have faced
daunting challenges and they've embraced
the adventure President Trump was
briefly taken to the White House
underground bunker had deferments
because I had a foot thing and I get
that deferment for that it's brutal
it's absolutely and completely brutal
and just like wow wow wow wow so that
that was not good not good the hype
train continues on twitch I want to say
thanks to Dekker boy and cinder soul we
only have 38 seconds left to complete
the level 4 hype train can we do it can
we do it oh boy I don't think we
actually can people demanding a
different hairstyle if we achieve level
4 hype train I okay i'll rico my hair if
people really want that boom there it is
okay we did it I love it when people say
no you're not going to do it and then we
do it thanks to in I'm inconsolable
gifting 10 subscriptions okay alright
let's see I will do a little something
different we'll do a little bit of a
Beatles thing there we go
makes it kind of hard to see but I will
try to do this for as long as I can read
the Super chats let's see here
other Super chats coming in hold on a
second where are these economic numbers
okay G Egan says what is the chance of
removing Trump pre-election zero I just
it it's five months away you're not
removing him before the election we know
what to do remove him in November that's
it dev rod says thoughts on economic
numbers Friday
you think there are truthful thoughts on
the report from an Italian doctor that
kovat is losing its potency haven't seen
the report have a clip coming out about
the numbers already recorded charlie
it says David for us non twitch users
what the heck is a hype train a hype
train is basically just a counter that
pops up on the screen and as people get
twitch memberships it fills up that it's
rude that's really all it is and
sometimes people know they get fired up
about it and you know that's what it I
actually can't see a damn thing with my
hair like this so I'm just gonna have to
there we go that's better
Stephanie Meyers says I love the Kaylee
McKenna knee is driving me crazy look
yeah
Murch where Ireland says you look like a
troll doll from the 90s
Carmen Edwards says this moment is and
time is a reminder when the Republican
and Democrat switched sides during civil
war I'm not exactly sure I understand
that one a Koyo Madrid sent a super chat
but then issued a retraction Matias
Germany says what's your first drink
after Trump loses I guess I you know
make a nice vodka soda
Cory Keene says here in the USA it seems
so chaotic this concept of two parties
going back and forth so much propaganda
this is how it is in other civilized
countries sadly that is how it is here
and it is ugly azim Abu Khalil says in
regards to those who are critical of the
BLM movement specifically their
purported narratives views initiatives
what do you make of people like Coleman
Hughes John McWhorter and Glenn Lowry
I'm only a little familiar with what
they say and I don't know enough about
their views to really comment Janelle
asks whether I would Rock a man bun I
did on a stream two weeks ago so now I
could more than easily do it but I am
getting a haircut on Friday so well you
know here's what I'll do
I will offer up one final man bun
if we get to 25 members today I will do
it like I'm sure there will be a stream
tomorrow or Wednesday this may be the
last opportunity before the haircut
happens and speaking of new members I
want to say thanks to Annie furrow
whose new member number one on my
website and Aaron dang who is new member
number two on my website you can
subscribe at join pakman.com a beautiful
website it's a perfect website I would
even say Marika L says I don't care
about hair but glad you took a machete
to the beard jungle oh boy
Matt Chavez has two son made recording
police illegal First Amendment violation
I I did not hear about that I'm gonna
look into them Daniel doc has subscribed
on YouTube so his Kevin Dunham Trevor
says love your show David just want to
remind everyone that if they participate
in the protests get a CO vid test ASAP I
agree I agree you've got to do it it the
protests will spread the virus the
question is how much and can we quickly
trace and isolate but yes absolutely
thank you to God's son 58 for the twitch
Prime subscription I'm inconsolable has
now gifted 311 subscriptions on Twitch
311 grew up listening to 311 in fact 311
s bassist peanut is a big david pakman
show fan in that he follows me on
Twitter that's all but no 311 is a great
band and of course that has nothing to
do with I'm inconsolable but I'm
inconsolable incredibly has gifted 311
subscriptions which is unbelievable okay
dev rod says I am afraid Trump will use
videos of Biden touching kids faces and
waists against him how should bind Biden
counter this can he Biden should just
keep doing what he's doing he's up 14 in
the latest CNN poll Derek Cunningham
says what constitutional crisis would
happen if Trump gets elected and says I
don't
rather than I do regarding the oath of
office I've never heard anyone ask or
comment on this never gonna happen
don't even think about it not gonna
happen
Seth Barham says hey David my Clippers
are arriving today you can get a haircut
in North Carolina but I still think it's
risky even though people are living as
if kovat is gone so there's another
perspective so to speak on on the
haircut situation yeah here in
Massachusetts haircuts have been open
for a couple of weeks now cases keep
declining I would wear a mask
my hairdresser would wear a mask and the
customers are spaced out you wait in
your car until it's time to go in I
think it would be okay I think it would
be okay
but I could be talked out of it by by
the end of the week we'll see let me say
a huge thank you to Noll
Laura no Laura is new member number
three on my website join pakman.com let
me briefly interject we do the podcast
we do the YouTube clips we do the twitch
streams the YouTube streams Facebook
Twitter all of this different stuff it's
all mostly funded by people who say hey
you know what
sorry it froze there people who say hey
you know what just go to join pakman.com
and get yourself a membership it's
really cheap it's the number one way to
support the show you will fill up this
bar and if we get to 25 website members
my next stream I will bring back the
man-bun last opportunity because Friday
I'm getting a haircut people wondering
about my strawberry video it's probably
happening today or tomorrow I have out
in my garden I have a strawberry plant
with one ripe strawberry it's the first
year for this plant my plan is I'm gonna
pick the strawberry pick one mint leaf
and with a fork and huge chef's knife
have a meal of a single backyard grown
strawberry with mint that's the idea and
I may be filming that the the strawberry
is almost at peak ripeness so I may be
filming that today or tomorrow and it's
going to be a beautiful thing but
as far as the memberships go 20/20 now
coupon code you save 66% everybody loves
it we have a huge party every time
somebody gets a membership it's only a
couple bucks a month if you pay for the
year it's only $1 80 a month if you
can't afford that don't do it I mean
literally I don't want your last dollar
but if you are somebody who is doing
okay financially and a dollar eighty or
two bucks a month works for you we
really do appreciate your support we are
independently funded the primary funding
source is folks who sign up and
everybody will get a thank you let's see
here um where did I leave off okay
Okoye yo Madrid says had some incorrect
vocabulary
I took a mental health break recently
it's good to be back to see your show
stay awesome I'm a super fan keep it up
thank you I appreciate that
ceruse Palmer or Cyrus Palmer says
Caylee is looking super Orange probably
trying to normalize Trump's hassles with
Ludacris race heads yeah can you imagine
Caylee I'm gonna need you to go to
shades more orange so that I look less
crazy
in comparison Arun Mehta says did you
see the statue being toppled in Bristol
UK I did not if it happened over the
weekend I mostly took the weekend off
from politics Barack Obama says David
when are you gonna admit you've been
mani towing your girlfriend I don't even
know what that means I hope it's not
racist
Carmen Edwards says okay I was talking
about when the parties were different
during the Civil War the Republicans
were like Democrats and Democrats were
like Republicans think the parties may
switch like that again I don't think
we're gonna see that anytime soon Carmen
but that is an interesting historical
element for sure Michael says I'm a
supporter on YouTube and Facebook
where's the love David right here
Michael thank you I appreciate that very
much thank you so much rip City
rapscallions says over under Kaley will
answer seven questions I think she will
take seven questions
I believe we will get essentially no
answers from her essentially no answers
from her if you were watching on twitch
I will again last week I did something
crazy
we had a multistream going and at a
certain point in the stream I pinched
off all streams other than twitch and
then we blew the phone lines open and
took phone calls from people watching on
twitch we are likely going to do that
again this week and this is I really
want to be careful here I'm saying this
with total peace and love I mean real I
say this with the utmost respect for
whatever reason when I open the phone
lines when I'm only streaming on Twitch
the call quality is better I don't mean
the audio quality I mean the questions
are better it seems to go better I'm not
trying to offend anybody on YouTube I'm
not trying to offend anybody on Twitter
or Facebook
it's just when I open the phone lines
and we're streaming in different places
it's an absolute and total [ __ ] show but
for whatever reason when we open on
Twitch the calls are good they're not
all friendly and that's fine but I don't
know why it is so this is why I again
this week I may do another night time
stream maybe tomorrow or Wednesday and
then at a certain point in time we'll
pinch off all non twitch streams and we
will open the phone lines and I think
it's going to be it's it's really the
vanguard of progressive politics I would
say okay there are people saying that
this is close to starting let me refresh
here see what we've got
yeah the stream hasn't been auto
starting which is weird oh okay all
right very good we're getting very very
close
let's see what's happen we're in the
room on the White House stream as well
beautiful so we'll turn the sound up
good so we are standing by okay so
anyway the point is no matter where
you're watching make sure you're at
least following me at twitch.tv slash
David Pakman and then you will be
notified when the phone calls happen
let's see who else is signing up over on
my website Stefon Way has made a patreon
pledge I'm going to count it
I'm gonna counted as supporter number
for today kay Roselle has signed up on
my website and his supporter number five
Nicola Fran is new member number six
today well that was weird um cat Jan is
new member number seven I also want to
say thank you to Lisa Tharp who is new
member number eight thank you Lisa
and Amber Fraley is new member number
nine Thank You amber very much
appreciate that a lot of people taking
advantage of that coupon code right
above my head which saves you sixty-six
percent it's stunning it's absolutely
stunning
okay we are standing by for Kaylee Magga
nanny and she should be out very very
soon oh she's gonna come out strongly
over the next short period of time
Brody Andrew Mulligan says can we get a
live stream of the garden someday yeah
maybe maybe we'll look into that we're
looking at it captain frank says went
from melon to salamander in terms of
orange Azim abu khalil says given how
recent circumstances are likely to
prolong the pandemic do you think
institutions like schools are likely to
remain closed well into fall I believe
that you will see schools open in the
fall but that it may they may then end
up having to close again oh that was
weird maybe that's actually an idea
alright here we go this is my new
hairstyle
hello everyone the transition to
greatness has officially begun to say
the absolute least the jobs in this
country we had more than 2.5 million
added the prediction was that 7.5
million jobs would be lost this was a 10
million swing toward the positive side
and in fact the greatest number of jobs
created in a single month on record I
predicted this 2 weeks ago that this is
exactly the line they would come up with
we've never grown so quickly
4,000 construction jobs and 1.2 million
leisure and hospitality jobs were all
added in May
beyond that the number of workers who
reported being on temporary layoffs
decreased by 2.7 million in May and more
than that and this was a great number
that was pointed out to me today by the
CEA 300 300,000 jobs were created for
black Americans in particular May and
that was a 1.7 percent increase so very
encouraging numbers there from the CEA
that they highlighted for me BLS numbers
that they highlighted maize jump in
average weekly hours also is an
encouraging sign because increasing
hours is a sign that employees need to
hire employers need to hire more workers
to meet demand work for all private
sector employees average weekly hours
increased by 0.5% to thirty four point
seven hours the highest level since the
series began in 2006 73% of small
businesses are open that is up from the
52% right before the April jobs report
reference period also workplace visits
are up roughly 40 percent from its pay
understand that a lot of businesses are
now marginally open because they've lost
unemployment protections and they are
not making money that actually keeps
them sustainable important to understand
that in President Trump the jobs
president who created the hottest
economy a modern history once and will
do it again
oh my god also commentators and
economists have noted how great this
jobs report was yesterday we saw Mohamed
el-erian the chief economic advisor at
Allianz say this will go down in his
as the biggest positive data shock for
the markets in the economy and you saw
how surprised the markets were they
surged on Friday capping a strong week
with the Nasdaq closing at a record high
he said it was also very surprising to
the economists not a single one thought
that we would create jobs everybody
expected the unemployment rate would go
up it did not also senior economic
correspondent understand that the real
unemployment rate was in a footnote in
that report I've got a story coming out
about it in a couple hours so I won't
you know do the story now Porter's
obviously the President signed that into
law and has been a been a big
cheerleader of the PPP typical
economists missed it by 10 million as I
noted at the top of the briefing 10
million that's bigger than the entire
state of Michigan nearly and that's how
much economists were off fact-check
economists predicted a 20% unemployment
peak and indeed the real number last
month was nineteen point seven who s
heard in the hottest economy in modern
history
record low unemployment for black
Americans for Hispanic Americans for the
disabled for our veterans paychecks were
beginning to rise under the president
Donald Trump economy we have the great
jobs creator in office and America
clearly has confidence in this president
you have a president who fundamentally
understands how to put this country back
to work know that we saw that in action
with the Friday jobs report and with
that I'll take questions wow it's like a
90 second briefing John what's the
president's thinking on this growing
movement we
defund or dismantle police forces across
the country and what reforms does the
president think would be appropriate in
the wake of the George Floyd killing
yeah it's a really good question
she will not is appalled by the defund
the police movement the fact that you
have sitting Congress women wanting to
defund the police notably Rasheeda Talib
notably Biden advisor aoc Alexandria by
the way I'm against this defund movement
and I'll tell you why in a 15-minute
clip coming up later and part of this is
exactly why this even being a story is
bad for Democrats and I'll explain it
all later on Farr and they couldn't
possibly go farther because we all
remember the defund ice movements they
want to defund and it was a Polish
custom enforcement and now they wanted
to fund the police this is extraordinary
this is rolling back the protective
layers that protect Americans in their
homes and in their places of business
he's appalled by it and it's remarkable
to hear this coming from today's
Democrat Party as for solutions he's
talking through a number of proposals no
announcements on that but he definitely
as he's noted recognizes the horrid
injustice by George Floyd and is taking
a look at various proposals ok president
agree with any of the mayors across the
country who were saying I think we can
take some of the money from policing and
put it toward other programs that could
be effective in Community Development
which could lead to the potential for
and let's a lesser need for policing
well let's be clear the mayor of LA
wants to defund police take money away
from police a mayor de Blasio the mayor
of New York wants to take money away
from police that means cutting of police
Emmys reducing Police Department's that
means defunding police Tibet's not true
you can do away with programs that for
example increase the militarization of
police departments and this is why you
don't need a sledgehammer here you need
a velvet glove my friends does the
president feel
systemic racism and law enforcement the
president's been very clear there in
justices and society I've noted several
for you that he's pointed out as a
Republican primary candidate noting the
Sandra bland video was absolutely
horrible
noting George Floy there's a civil
rights investigation into that he
definitely believes there instances of
racism but look he believes our law
enforcement are the best in the world he
believes that by and large they are good
people the 750 who were injured
defending this country from rioters in
antifa in the streets as to be
protesters those 750 officers who were
hurt defending our country or heroes as
was David Dorn a police officer who lost
his life and Patrick Underwood who also
lost his life in the last week or so not
a thing that there's systemic racism in
law he believes most of our police
officers are good a lot of people and
there's a lot of evidence of that and he
has great faith in our Police Department
well that's a good question does he
still believe that NFL players who kneel
as a form of protest against police
brutality should be fired the president
is very much against kneeling in general
the president has made clear for years
the killing is tied to our National
Anthem that it does not respect our
military men again sitting cross-legged
is wrong he's not a fan of the kneeling
movement he's made that very clear
particularly because he thinks it's
disrespectful to our military as the
kneeling originated at the kneeling
during the national anthem I think they
should be fired I have no comments on
that he is against the kneeling movement
though as he's noted on Twitter as
recently as a few days ago yes yes I
have no information on that and I have
not talked to him about that really
think of the Democrats
leasing Act that the administration
supports yeah that legislation first of
all the text of it hasn't even been
giving yes I've not talked with the
president about that yet he hasn't
reviewed it yet he's looking at a number
of proposals but there are some non
starters in there I would say
particularly they should just keep
asking questions about Trump in
different positions like does the
president find the term sitting
indian-style offensive or does he not
find that offense just make all the
questions about sitting which is not
advisable so he hasn't reviewed the
legislation but AG bar as a member of
the administration noted this prior to
the proposal coming out does the
administration support the banning of
the use of chokehold
look the president again hasn't reviewed
this piece of legislation the president
is looking at what's a state issue
what's a federal issue right now he's
currently reviewing proposals actually
on this very topic about police reform
so I'll leave it to him and not get
ahead of him on that but it's certainly
from sitting somewhere right now reading
through thick binders with proposals can
you imagine action with an individual
with two weeks after all of this civil
unrest why does the lame at the White
House not have a plan the president said
on Friday that his plan for combating
racism is a strong economy how does that
work well that's an important part of
combatting racism is making sure that
there's equal opportunity for black
Americans in this country this president
you know we hear a lot of words from
Democrats about criminal justice reform
that they wanted this well they got it
with President Trump reducing racial
sentencing disparities via the first
step backed you know Democrats talk
about economic opportunity for black
Americans on people in vulnerable
communities and this president has done
that with Opportunity Zones it was a
good start more than 900 places creating
private investment to help people get on
their feet to start businesses in this
country HBCUs record funding this brucy
been released repeatedly through his
actions I stood up for the black
community and a big piece of that is
absolutely economic reform I'd finally
note on the point of economic reform the
u.s. MCA these trade deals the TPP
making sure that didn't take place that
directly advantaged hard-working men and
women in Detroit who wanted their auto
jobs so his Reformation with trade
reformation with trade and also
Opportunity Zones is helping to and
sure that Americans of all races have
the same opportunity in the economic
place say you will eventually have a
police reform plan he's looking at
various proposals so I won't get ahead
of him no announcements on that front
but he has been looking at them over the
last few days there are reports that the
administration is going to be pulling
troops from Germany can you say how many
yeah what I would say on that is first
we have no announcements at this time I
know there's reporting out there but as
of this moment there are no
announcements on the president's
continually reassessing the best posture
for the United States military forces
and our presence overseas I'm a week
remain committed to working with our
strong allies I saw Angela Merkel before
making a final decision I'll leave that
to the president again no announcement
says she doesn't know guys just know the
new Lafayette Square fencing do you have
any indication yeah you know I don't
have any announcements with regard to
the fencing that's not something that's
in White House control in terms of
securing the perimeter but what I would
say is the president has recognized that
the protests have largely been peaceful
why have they been peaceful thanks to
him of the actions taken by this
administration oral notice Minneapolis
was in chaos until the National Guard
came in and then it was secure you had
outside here in Lafayette Park I noted
the 750 law enforcement officers that
were injured across the country well
one-fifth of those were in DC and the
vast majority the violent protests were
because of Obama the calm protests were
thanks to Trump Monday decision by the
president of encouraging governor's to
surge national guard made the difference
and the president's recognize now that
the protests are peaceful he's
recommended a winding down of the
national guard very peaceful protests
over the weekend so with regard to the
security of the building not a decision
for the White House would refer you to
Secret Service and Park Service's on
that but the president has recognized
the peaceful would they be able to give
us the attendance of some of those and
compare them to the Trump inauguration
when will the administration revoke on
Hong Kong's trade status and also do you
think that that move would be the only
thing the administration does is there
something else planned and do you think
that China will listen are you seeing
any signs of try to relent on Hong Kong
yeah we haven't seen any updates from
China thus far no announcements with
regards to the timing of that but the
president has been very clear that
China's replaced its promise of one
country two systems' with one country
one system which is what led the
administration to make the announcement
that it would begin eliminating policy
exemptions that were given to Hong Kong
the special treatment that they once had
right
a week after what we saw a lot day apart
last Monday night there eight people
here in this building who believe that
or does the president believe that
perhaps things went the way they
shouldn't have gone
is there any regret on a part of the
president no or anyone here about how
people were treated people who are
peacefully protesting and how they were
rushed out so violently no there's no
regrets on the part of this White House
look I'd note that many of those
decisions were not made here within the
White House it was a G bar who made the
decision to move the perimeter Monday
we're not we don't regret it because we
didn't do anything anything that
happened had nothing to do with us I'm
sin Lafayette Square and when before
these protesters were moved by Park
Police and they issue that tactical
order there were three loud warnings and
as I believe was AG bar on Face the
Nation noted that some of those
protesters move back and adhere to the
warning but others of those protesters
started hurling objects and that was
unacceptable and park police acted as
they felt they needed to at that time in
response right and we stand by those
actions the country in the world saw the
this violent clash between people who
were otherwise peacefully protesting but
really the president is not sorry for
the way things went no
sorry about the fact that an Tifa wreaks
havoc in our streets and the failure of
some members of the media to note that
since been widely debunked by the FBI
Washington field office supposed to be
peaceful well I'd point him to the First
Amendment where it says that you have
the right to quote peaceably assemble he
should go back and read oh how they care
about the First Amendment oh okay ara
Clemmons saying that writings a
mechanism to restructure our country
burning down st. John's using a pictu to
literally like carve out as we saw that
wait a second a church was burned down
what is that did I miss that the church
was burned down saying the actions of
actions of the rioters were not in
keeping with the First Amendment and I
think the media needs to recognize
there's a discernment between the
peaceful protesters many of whom I've
seen and the rioters and yes America
will act against rioters and yes under
President Trump he will not allow
burning buildings 150 federal buildings
to be deface and 750 law-enforcement
officers to be injured in our country
can I ask you one more guess I just I
like the blue suit just to follow up on
that oh you you do know that the burning
of st. John's happened on Sunday nights
and a lot of the violence that you're
talking about that happened on Sunday
night what he was asking about me from
Monday when as anyway
this assumes that we counseling The
Bachelor presidents before the chemical
munitions be used on those protesters so
do you just want to clarify that about
the burning of st. John's is that
happened on a different day yeah the
burning of st. John's is what prompted
the decision to move the perimeter it's
what prompted Park needs to say that
evening but they didn't bun moved it's
what prompted yes it's what prompted AG
bar to agree with that decision on
Monday morning that the bottle needed to
be moved so police when you don't move
after three orders are given at Park
Police a-- it's the most efficient
government of our time and yet based on
what happens Sunday night they talked
about it Monday morning and did it five
minutes before Trump walked over there
okay yeah Mitt Romney can say three
words outside on Pennsylvania Avenue but
I would note this that President Trump
won eight percent of the black vote Mitt
Romney won two percent of the black vote
I believe president is bragging about
having eight percent of the black vote
oh my god he has a lot of words notably
he said that forty seven percent of the
nation is dependent upon government
believes they are victims believes that
the government was there for them those
were Mitt Romney's words not too long
ago brother president takes great
offense to those words oh yeah that's
not America guess what America is it's
when given opportunity via a trump
opportunity I believe that Americans of
all races can rise to the occasion and
achieve belief in HBCUs and giving fun
defunding record funding to HBCUs
because I need to enable an education in
our country and school choice those kind
of actions on the part of the president
running against the black president
Romney didn't get as much of the black
vote as Trump did oh okay no the
president's talking about the protest
he's talked about
the death of George Floyd but he still
hasn't given a formal address to the
nation
what has that an order plans for him to
do that anytime soon so the president
has addressed the nation on this I know
several media outlets chose not to cover
it but when he was down at in Florida
last Saturday he said and I have the
whole thing here as he said many times
the death of George Boyd on the street
the thing where he tried to take credit
for SpaceX he also mentioned something
about race minutes going through this in
fact half of his speech saying I
understand the pain that people are
feeling we support the right of peaceful
protesters we hear their pleas and he
went on and on and on he said on Monday
I am your president of law and order and
an ally of peaceful protesters so he has
said it some of the media have chosen
not to cover it those words are out
there and they're documented yes
evany thank you obviously we're hearing
a very optimistic message from the
president about the jobs numbers and the
stock market recovery but in a executive
order on Thursday night the president
said that he'd determined that without
intervention the u.s. faced the
likelihood of a long economic recovery
with assistant high unemployment I'm
just wondering why we're hearing true
messages from the president and how the
American people are supposed to feel
about the economy seize Friday as a
great stride toward what he ultimately
wants which is this rearing economy that
we had where paychecks were growing and
at the fastest for low-income workers
we're at a very good place before he
chose to stop the economy not to save
two point one remember that Trump didn't
do that that's revisionist history state
governors seeing the numbers made
decisions and then at some point way
late Trump CDC put out some guidelines
that is a completely inaccurate version
of how this all went down Beck did note
that the market believes in this
president that employers believe in this
president that they they believe they
can open their doors in the Trump
economy so it was a note of a great
first step of progress but rest assured
there are many more steps that we have
to take to get back to the hottest
economy of modern he's not an answer
under President Trump
yes sir second with the economy New York
City began over reopening its economy
today after a very long lockdown does
President Trump think we need another
coronavirus stimulus package and if so
what would he want to see in it before
he signed it yeah he's remained open to
a phase four there was some discussion
about this there's a meeting last week
at the White House about that actually
so I won't get ahead of him but he has
said there are several things he wants
payroll tax holiday was one of them
because that directly advantages
low-income workers
I'm several that's a distortion of what
it does and you should check out my
YouTube clip about it called I made a
mistake and I'm sorry I have a youtube
clip called I made a mistake and I'm
sorry and I addressed that policy idea
I'd have run their states into the
ground because of decades of Democrat
policies Chanel thank you
when President Trump supports an actual
increase in funding to help offset some
of the damage that's almost
yeah so again that would be getting
ahead of the president on that exact
proposal but he's been very clear he
does not support defunding the police in
any way shape or form
hey how about does the president want to
give the police even more money so to me
that we have seen violent crime couldn't
come down in this country and why at the
time when violent crimes coming down why
would we defund the police who are in
large part responsible for helping
America to get to a place where our
streets are safe so like you I would
point you to that
and before getting ahead of the
president a specific policy for this
movement was going on
how does it be back you said sorry I
didn't you funding the police but how
does it impact the crime scenarios the
kinds of grants that we enough do you
think that will impact the crime yeah
absolutely look our police officers are
the ones who are defending this country
and making sure that we have law and
order in our streets she's more and she
doesn't know what's going on you look at
the wrong numbers they our police are
described as the blue line in American
society between peace and chaos between
order and Anarchy and that thin blue
line has done quite a bit just looking
at 2018 numbers
murder arrest 11 1970 robbery arrest
eighty eight thousand 130 aggravated
assault three hundred ninety five
thousand eight hundred violent crime
arrests 495 thousand nine hundred that's
police officers who are doing the
arresting you eliminate police officers
you will have chaos crime in anarchy in
the streets and that's something that's
unacceptable to the president
politically motivated this movement this
movement what the President believes is
look when you look at I would just take
at their own words black lives matter DC
and black lives matter DC said black
lives matter means to fund the police so
if that's what the movement means of
course the president stands against
defunding the police all black lives
matter including the life of David Dorn
who perished in the last week and a half
including Patrick underwear would who
also lost his life on this week all
black lives matter but in terms of the
movement black lives matter they defined
themselves as defund the police and
that's something this president stands
against right yes
blacks are disproportionately arrested
and disproportionately incarcerated in
this country and when they return to
society they are often denied the right
to vote sometimes for the rest of their
lives is the president concerned about
this disparity disparity and does the
president favor restoring the rights of
all those who complete their sentences
so that they can participate in the that
issue specifically but what I would note
is your question does edge on the last
thing Trump wants is more people voting
so the answer is No
hopefully incarcerated that we need to
address that situation and the president
has with the first-step act a great
piece of legislation that says pregnant
women can't be shackled when they're
having their baby in jail these are
basic common-sense human decency reforms
that the president put in place the
sentencing disparities that are a play
because of the Violent Crime Control and
Law Enforcement Act of 1994 that crime
bill which has been derided and
rightfully so by civil rights leaders
this president helped in part to rectify
that and I'd note that the first step
back the beneficiaries more than 90%
have been black Americans so this is a
president who's always stood on the side
of justice but I have not spoken to him
about that specific right I Missouri do
you want to do is on they're both gotten
to yes Emily thank you
I'd like to ask a question on behalf of
myself and then one for McCauley
couldn't be here sure so many complaints
were made against Derrick Chauvin prior
to the death of towards Floyd and I was
wondering if President Trump believes
that disciplinary records and complaints
against police as well as police
personnel files should be accessible to
the public
states have different laws on this but
should there be a minimum national
standard on police I proposed back to
these complaints yes it's a good
question but again it would get to what
the president's going to propose going
forward so I won't address that or get
ahead of that but the particular
incidents you referenced of George Floyd
it was egregious and that needs to be
looked at and is being looked at not
just at the state level but I did love
the DOJ as well
Thank You Ann from a colleague does
president Trump urge Prince Andrew to
comply with his Department of Justice's
request for an interview in the case
against Jeffrey Epstein I haven't spoken
to him on about that so I wouldn't say
is there any thought being given to
returning to not a daily coronavirus
briefing frequent coronavirus briefings
and no on the reopening the president
said some we expect that he would
continue to monitor the situation and
that if any states were doing things
that he
they were appropriate he would step in
to intervene as the president in any of
these reopening particularly as
coronavirus cases are increasing which
could be doing part due to increased
testing is he seeing anything that gives
him insight so I would note this first
my dr. Burke sent me some new
information before coming out here that
new cases have stabilized and many of
the new cases are being identified
through proactive monitoring and finding
asymptomatic cases today we saw the
lowest new mortality report since the
end of March less than 500 and testing
continues to expand with over 20 million
done and more than 6% of Americans being
tested and in seven states nearly 10% of
the population so we are heading in a
positive direction even as we began to
safely reopen as the president seen
anything and the question is are there
going to be press briefings that was
part one of the question bridging signs
put forward by dr. Burks on he's seen
the country safely reopen and I would
also just note some of the media
contradictions here certainly not
referring to you specifically John but
just a little more broadly that there
isn't and I'll cry about social
distancing among the protests and I mean
I saw one Network for edge of the Ozarks
and complaining about social do serious
leftists like me have been pointing out
that the virus doesn't discriminate at
protests in terms of why you're doing it
obviously if there are more masks that's
good but know this this is just the BS
narrative and I really wanted to get in
should have weaved in an earlier but I
think it's important it's just there's
so much focus on our police officers
right now there are absolute cases of
injustice 'as our heart breaks for those
cases but I just want to note some of
the great things our police have done
last year alone in Alaska retired cop
Kim this doesn't have anything to do
with using water to help victims to
safety after a plane crash in Idaho a
woman said he saved my son's life
commenting on a cop the problem isn't
that most cut listen most cops are doing
a great job and that's why you can
easily find stories it doesn't deal with
the problems intervening and someone got
somebody water in Alaska oh okay all
right
sorted amassed
in Ohio police took down a mass shooter
at a bar in Wisconsin a terminally
terminally ill girl was visited by 40
officers and canines and New York
officers buys an officer Roman of the
NYPD responded to an incident involving
a homeless man they bought him new
glasses a haircut and a new suit and
they helped him to find a job cops are
supposed to be doing good things and the
response to cops doing bad things is to
say a lot of cops are doing their job
playing dolls with them on the street in
an Arizona Charley called 911 asking for
a happy meal mistakingly mistakenly and
police delivered this is who our great
law enforcement officers are and we
should remember that thank you so much
what a pathetic press briefing and
really as expected because things are
imploding things are completely
imploding I mean you know you only have
to look at this to understand how poorly
things things are going for this
president so a very very embarrassing
press briefing once again let me thank
the great people who signed up on my
website to support our work during this
stream April Ferrer is new member number
10 carl stan borsky is a new member
number 11 i also want to say thanks to
Camille Todd whose new member number 12
Alex Haley is new member number 13
Katherine Foy is number 14 also a big
thank you to alcohol who is new member
number 15 and also why not Alex Haley
supporting on patreon and we're gonna
count that as well as number 16 really
really appreciate everybody's support of
the stream sorry I was not able to get
to every super chat we will have another
stream again very very soon including a
nighttime stream this week during which
I will take your phone calls I will see
you then
you